what's going on there people we're gonna
watch ourselves the moon night super
bowl tv spot here there's a good amount
of new footage in here we got koi with
us who he knows moon knight a little bit
better than john if you guys can leave a
like that would be very much appreciated
also follow corner's youtube channel man
he is thebomb.com let's get to it
[Music]
i can't tell the difference
oh
between my waking life
and dreams
must be very difficult
with a voice
in your head
it's chaos in here
ah the moon came
yes
yes
oh that's that's the joy i was hoping
for oh that was sad okay
that is like 30 seconds of pure
unadulterated glee oh that was beautiful
you know for a 30-second spot just
giving us extensions and expansions upon
scenes that we saw in the previous one
what's so smart with the cadence use of
the music to like hey by the way it's
only 30 seconds but bring you in i love
the fact that they use it day and night
it really complements i'd say oscar
isaac the actor very well also this is
reminding me of what i wanted spawn to
be like it gave me like good spawn vibes
like what i hoped spawn would be you
know i was thinking that i mean we got
to talk a little bit more about the
footage here but i i was seeing that i
think i saw you talking about online the
mr knight footage oh dude okay mr knight
yeah who we'll i thought they would show
him in here especially was in the
article but surprisingly they didn't
because i i would i if i was putting on
a trailer i'd be like 30 seconds of old
stuff 29 seconds one second mr knight if
you're gonna put it out in the empire
thing mr knight is another persona of
moon knight who is more of a detective
more of a sleuth kind of a pompous he's
got like an arrogance to him they all do
but he's especially like whatever but
what's cool about him is that would
allow a different nuance to if one is
super reckless is one is doing all this
you've got one guy that might be trying
to like wrangle them and control the
madness and that was introduced in the
uh warren ellis declan shalvie run which
wasn't until moon knight had been around
for like 45 years so mr knight is deep
in the mythology some of the only
kickback has been that mr knight was
being introduced too soon but that's the
difference between adaptation and
translation you don't want to translate
comic books to screen you want to adapt
them to screen it doesn't always make
sense to tell your stories in
chronological order doesn't always make
sense to have the characters evolve in
the same way because you're gonna have
oscar isaac being able to give you a lot
more information with nuance glances
than even a panel can so what you want
to do is make sure that you've got an
eye line and i think our eye line to
mark spectre's insanity is going to be
mr knight
clip it i stopped listening halfway
through
i know
i had a lot to say about myself when are
we gonna get pizza i do need pizza i was
promised pizza i don't know what the
score is is there a game i don't even
care i'm locked in this room right now m
m's performing at bed oh no
the only thing whiter than moonlight
actually i have this thing here that i
they released the official synopsis for
this and i remember when we were doing
the official trailer reaction um a
little bit ago that we were like oh in
the comic they actually mainly follow
mark spector at first according to the
marvel.com their their synopsis is the
series follows steven grant a
mild-mannered gift shop employee who
becomes plagued with blackouts and
memories of another life stephen
discovers he has disassociative identity
disorder and shares a body with mark
spector as steven mark's enemies
converge upon them they must navigate
their complex identities while thrust
into a deadly mystery among the powerful
gods of egypt they're kind of doing a
reversal which kind of works within the
who the moon knight character is instead
of following mark spector at first and
then discovering the other personalities
we're going to hang out with uh stephen
grant and that was something i kind of
theorized in our trailer breakdown was
like i'd be wondering if he's going to
find out how moon knight happened while
finding out he is actually mark spector
like uncovering his og that's that's
trippy yeah that's more expected i was a
mercenary and now i'm a moon knight and
also marva you know stephen grant's more
likeable as a human being he's more like
person he's more expected the guy's
named mark spectre and his movement
he makes a little bit more like
digestible in that way because by the
time you're in episode three you're like
bro's name is mark spectre uh like it
kind of works out to normalize those
things but it's also really interesting
you see conscious in the opening of this
30 seconds where it's like enveloping
them and it looks like uh not
willingly like it looks like there's a
bit of a takeover so it might be
interesting to see mark spector take
over stephen grant might be interesting
to see the moonlight take over embodying
it because konshu definitely looks like
an antagonist and he is in the comic
books while also being the thing that
moon knight follows konchi is this
foreboding presence this ominous thing
that tells him what to do but it's not
always willingly you know kevin feige
was actually speaking about recently and
i'm curious here john's last on this was
speaking about recently how this one
they really are pushing the envelope in
terms of how dark they can go so it
sounds like they are really trying to
actually push the envelope on can we get
violent you know and then with those
final moments too with uh my god i'm not
forgetting the name of the weapon you
know the name of the weapon what is that
weapon called moon dopeness
glittering it's one of his hands okay
yeah sure why not a mooney yeah john
talk on what i was talking on i'm
talking i would love to see an increase
in the caliber of darkness especially in
the physical realm i guess i am suspect
of a claim like that given i mean this
definitely does look like in terms of
just what lore and mythology it's
borrowing from it has potential to get
sort of dark and in a mystical sort of
darkness which can feel very occultish
which is very edgy i don't expect this
necessarily to be a step up in terms of
violence especially because there is a
fantasy element here but i can imagine
it feeling that much more intense and
that much more horror movie inspired and
what i do appreciate is that looking at
this as compared to dr strange you know
they both cross these mystical and
magical barriers yet they look totally
different from each other sure true and
this doesn't look like it's gonna get
swept up into that so i like that you
have this more personal and more
contained and potentially also horrific
in a totally opposite way story that's
about to unfold they just gave it a tv
14 rating today so it is a little bit
more brutal
more zesty also uh on march 1st which is
merely two weeks away
because they were made by they were
owned by marvel because their marvel
characters leased to netflix everybody's
like oh the netflix shows well yeah for
a time those shows could land on hulu
those shows could land at disney plus
and then you could build out this marvel
knights universe starting with moon
knight because moon knight and daredevil
are much more simpatico than your doctor
strange i honestly think fantastic four
is gonna lean doctor strange cosmic i
think daredevil's gonna lean mood knight
spider-man and i think that you're gonna
have this beautiful universe that isn't
just grounded in cosmic anymore you're
going to have grounded cosmic r-rated
supernatural blade likely not to cross
over with eternals again like that was a
water because that's going to go up here
and like it's going to be really cool
when you have even more people that
don't feel like comic books are the
thing to have this gateway like this is
a character that is unlike anything else
we've seen so far and it's going to
bring in new audiences and just like
harry styles will so i think with buying
the netflix stuff i think they would
want to put it on disney plus and then
they would have to figure out how to you
know
you know move the audience forward where
they can handle more r-rated material is
that they're going to have to eventually
get if you were eight years old when you
saw iron man you're 22 now i'm sorry to
say it that is just
so at the end of the day as we've
evolved this universe we have aged and i
think it is the way to keep this going
is having more r-rated things having you
know my boy deadpool be the proper tone
it was a fun little experiment with your
christmas movie i had fun i enjoyed it
that's not the character so if you want
moon knight you want deadpool you want
these characters you want people to
enjoy punisher you want johnny bernthal
to come over you play in the right
sandbox and in the european markets
you've got star i think is the name of
the network that
has you know a little bit more
adult-ready content so when they
announced that right now you've got
r-rated movies alongside disney plus
stuff in europe when they announced that
at d23 two years ago i was like oh
that's how you get deadpool maybe moon
night and daredevil is how all that
comes together and it looks like this is
the the beginning of that
i agree good i agree with your sentences
we should get pizza i agree with your
sentences not enough until lord of the
rings trailers
all right guys
your thoughts down below let's get to it